today two issues one the patriots a
lingering problem there although they
firmly believe they don't have an
outbreak they've added another player to
the covet 19 reserve list it's james
ferentz offensive lineman and the
standards have changed for how you get
on it now too it's not just a positive
test they're not going to screw around
with anyone who was in sufficiently
close contact with someone who is
positive because they don't want to take
the chance of getting the virus in the
building
if the person later does test positive
and it's smart because there is that lag
between when you collect the sample when
you get the result and the person could
be shedding virus in between so it seems
like the bar has gone up
or down whichever way results in more
placement on covet 19 reserve but
everything's still on shireen for the
patriots to host the broncos on sunday a
week later than it was supposed to
happen
yeah you know i was on the conference
call with dr alan seals the nfl's chief
medical officer twice this week
including yesterday and they're just
getting way more strict in you know with
cold and flu season coming up they don't
know if the symptoms that players report
are actually cold and flu symptoms or
are they coveted symptoms a lot of them
are the same between the two so they
don't know so they're going to send
people home
in lieu of anything else and then of
course if you get a a positive is it a
false positive or is it really a
positive so they i think they've learned
a lot through the patriot situation and
particularly through the tennessee
titans situation of what they need to do
and don't do and you look at a player
like matt pryor of the eagles who went
on the kova 19 reserve list uh today and
won't play on sunday well he didn't
actually test positive for covet what
happened was he came in and reported
someone that he was around did test
positive outside the organization and so
out of an abundance of caution they've
placed him on the coveted list so i
think we're going to see a lot more of
these mike
as we move forward just because we are
getting into cold and flu season and and
the symptoms are the same
a couple of things that put a lot of
faith in the honor system here because
when players realize they're getting
shut down for a game or a practice or
whatever because they were too candid
about who they were in contact with they
may just decide you know what
let's just let it ride let's see if i
test positive if it has positive then
it's an issue and there's plenty of guys
that think it's no big deal there's
plenty of people who think it's not even
a real thing in our society so it
wouldn't surprise me if some guys decide
to zip it when it comes to whether or
not there's someone in their household
that tested positive because they don't
want to be deprived of the ability to
play players want to get on the field
because they know if it's next man up
they may be out my other point is this
i wonder and i'm going to choose my
words carefully here to an extent i
wonder how much of the changes we've
seen
are the result of things the nfl has
learned that it couldn't have known
or
the nfl catching up to
what it should have been doing
all along and i say that for one very
important reason i got a ton of respect
for dr alan sills he's a brain guy not
an epidemiologist and that's a huge
distinction as it relates to the various
disciplines in the field of medicine you
know when i practice law i specialize in
labor and employment cases if somebody
came to me one day and said hey how'd
you like to handle medical malpractice
case i said how'd you like me to lose a
medical malpractice case because i'm not
suited to do it it's not where i've
concentrated my practice
and and i'd i'd love to know
exactly who the epidemiologists are that
the nfl is relying on and why there
isn't an epidemiologist running point
here and again i'm trying not to
disrespect dr sills but i think at some
level he's got to be thinking
how did i draw this short straw this
isn't my area of expertise no more than
we want dr anthony fauci to perform
brain surgery so there really is that
question i mentioned it because a coach
raised with me not that long ago when we
look at the struggles the nfl
currently
is having
the question is
is it bad players or is it a bad
playbook
and we really don't know and there's
really no way to know
yeah there is no way to know mike and i
know this i know alan sills is the face
for the nfl he comes out and speaks
whenever they have press conferences to
talk about covet 19. behind the scenes
we don't really know if he's the point
guy maybe they do have an expert in that
field
who is really running things who allen
seals is listening to and i know they
have several teams uh in the background
medical teams they have one for contact
tracing and they have one for actual
covet cases and and so they go those
directions once they have a positive
test they try to figure it out if it's a
false positive or a real positive and do
all the contract contact tracing and
everything else they need to do but he
is definitely the face for the nfl when
it comes to covet 19 cases whether he's
really running the show behind the
scenes that's what we don't know and we
don't know how many people they have or
really what they're doing and you're
right i think they have learned a lot
but did they start behind the eight ball
at the beginning not being fully
prepared we kept talking the off-season
oh they've got plenty of time they've
got plenty of time and there does seem
to be a point in there when they wasted
some of that time that they had
and some of these these things they're
learning on the fly maybe they should
have already known and should have been
prepared for from the get go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports